Alors avec nous pour notre panel
municipal : Luc Ferrandez
et Anie Samson.
Bonsoir à vous deux.
L'itinérance, je le disais
beaucoup, les gens, ça rend dans
une oreille et ça sort par
l'autre. On dit que ça a
toujours été comme ça et que ça
ne changera pas. Il y a un
caractère urgent depuis la
pandémie. Je le répète, on a
coupé 30 % des places dans les
endroits traditionnels, ce qui a
fait qu'il y avait une urgence
d'aller louer des motels tout
ça. Mais cela a créé et vous
l'avez vu dans Hochelaga, dans
Mercier, alors on fait quoi? On
demande plus d'argent à Québec?
Quel est le début d'une pièce de
solution
- Je pense que la ville aurait
pu aller plus loin. On dit que
c'est Québec qui paye, mais tout
ce qui va autour de cela, tout
ce qui est encadrement des
travailleurs de rue, des gens
qui sont là pour s'occuper des
personnes qui sont là, ce sont
des personnes qui ont souvent
des problèmes aussi
psychologiques, tout dépendant
de la sorte. Mais on a besoin de
support. Tu ne peux pas juste
les amener là alors disant de
faire attention parce qu'il y a
un code de vie et de ne pas
déranger les voisins. Ils ont
besoin d'avoir déjà vécu, de les
occuper, de parler. Ils ont
besoin d'avoir ce support et
c'est peut-être ça dans le
projet qui a dérangé les gens.
Et d'avoir des gens qui font le
lien avec les voisins aussi. On
ne peut pas juste les laisser
là. Il faut travailler des deux
côtés.
- Le citoyen nous disait : on
n'a pas vraiment été consulté et
on nous regarde un peu de haut
quand on dit que ce n'est pas
normal que mon jeune joug avec
des seringues.
- Là-dedans il y a du vrai et du
faux. C'est-à-dire qu'il y a 80
% des itinérants pour lequel la
fréquentation au quotidien n'est
pas difficile mais il y a un 20
% pour qui on ne peut pas
vraiment cette fréquentation
entre des enfants et E. On ne
veut pas de seringues sur le
territoire, pas de gens qui sont
dans un état second après avoir
fait de la drogue. Il y a du
vrai des deux côtés. Mais par
contre il y a beaucoup de villes
qui ont réussi à régler
itinérance en l'concentrant. Je
pense à Vancouver, à
Philadelphie. Cela donne des
déserts, c'est affreux. Ce sont
des villes de zombies. Des
endroits de zombies dans leur
allure. Les personnes restent
des humains mais ça donne une
impression. Et donc il ne faut
pas concentrer mais plutôt
répartir. À Montréal, il n'y a
pas de centre à peu près pas de
centre pour l'itinérance dans
l'Ouest, à peu près pas de
logement social dans l'Ouest. Je
serais curieux de voir par
rapport à l'population comme il
y en a Laval et combien il y en
a sur la rive sud. Il faut avoir
de plus petits centres et les
répartir et mieux s'en occuper.
- Dans les quartiers de l'Est,
les gens ne le faisaient
remarquer l'ordinateur Monsieur
Denis Coderre nous le disaient :
il disait : c'est toujours à
côté de chez nous.
- Il faut dire aussi que c'est
une dynamique qui est propre, ce
n'est pas juste parce qu'on a
mis l'eau motels à cet endroit
mais c'est parce qu'il y avait
aussi beaucoup d'itinérance.
Séparé à Melton Park, les
itinérants étaient présents
avant qu'on ouvre le refuge.
C'est vrai qu'il y a une
concentration permanente
toujours à Montréal pas et dans
l'est et au centre-ville.
- On ne peut pas non plus en
prenant le Royal Victoria, on ne
peut pas concentrer tout le
monde et on a vu qu'avec la
place du puits il y avait trop
de monde. Les solutions ne sont
pas infinies.
- Il n'y en a pas beaucoup et
surtout les gens, on ne peut pas
les déraciner non plus. Les
itinérants, tu les amènes
quelques pas et ils vont
retourner là où ils connaissent
le monde. Pour eux, c'est un
mode de vie ils sont habitués à
l'horizon, leurs amis et leur
coin de rue. C'est difficile
lorsqu'on les envoie ailleurs,
c'est normal qu'il soit dépaysé.
Ils n'ont plus les mêmes repas.
C'est pour ça qu'il faut un
encadrement et leur trouver des
activités, les replacer. La même
chose que les sapins qui Annie
Ohana au centre-ville parce que
c'est là que les gens se
ramassent.
- On va continuer et on va
questionner les candidats à la
mairie sur ces questions
d'itinérance. Il ne faut pas
oublier Québec non plus parce
que Québec doit payer les
organismes communautaires qui
s'occupent de ces gens et vous
disiez que si on veut une
meilleure cohabitation, ce qui
m'a surpris personnellement, ce
que Monsieur Pierre Lessard-
Blais, maire d'arrondissement de
ne pas aller à une fin de
rencontre. Les élus doivent
aussi faire face à la musique
aussi.
- Tout à fait. Est-ce qu'il a pu
penser à quelque chose auquel je
songe c'est-à-dire : si je vais
la Ruutu sera focalisé sur moi,
toutes les questions. Il a peut-
être voulu décentraliser la
discussion. Il y a une ville en
Finlande qui a réussi à régler
son problème de santé mentale
itinérance, une autre en
Nouvelle-Angleterre en faisant
quoi? En faisant du suivi
quotidien sur la santé mentale.
Ça, c'est Québec.
- D'accord.
On a façon différente d'avoir le
statut bilingue ou non de
Montréal. Alors les deux
candidats se sont consultés pour
savoir si on allait faire un
référendum.
- Ce qui me déçoit là-dedans,
c'est que pas plus tard que la
semaine passée, les deux ont
fait une conférence de presse
pour se joindre et l'entente
était qu'il prenait le parti du
mouvement Montréal et qui
donnait le poste de Monsieur
Desjardins en disant : on prend
mon programmeur ne parle pas du
bilinguisme parce que Montréal
est une ville française et on ne
parle pas du financement de la
police. C'était les deux
conditions sine qua non. Une
semaine plus tard aujourd'hui,
première grande sortie ensemble,
il va reprendre ses points comme
s'il avait oublié que la semaine
passée les deux c'était serré la
main avec une entente, donc le
mariage est donc la chicane est
prise dans le couple. Mais ce
qui est dommage qu'on va nulle
part avec ça. Ça me déçoit
beaucoup parce que la priorité à
Montréal n'est pas de savoir si
on est bilingue ou pas, on est
une ville francophone grande et
la métropole de l'Amérique du
Nord, les choses sont faites.
Les gens qui vivent en anglais
sont servis en anglais dans la
plupart des municipalités, ça se
fait à Montréal. Il n'y a
personne qui est biaisée ou qui
en pas pour cela, toutes les
mesures d'urgence sont
bilingues. Ce n'est pas un
problème. Je ne vois pas quelle
est l'urgence aujourd'hui de
repartir avec cela quand on
parle d'itinérance que quand on
part de sécurité, quand on part
de problèmes d'habitation. Je
pense que les vrais dossiers
devraient être cela. Aujourd'hui
je suis bien déçue.
- Je pense qu'il a une vision
complotiste prend pas compte de
tout ce qui précède en termes de
l'acquisition des sciences de
l'histoire. Il fait des
affirmations comme s'il était le
premier à faire des avis
affirmations et comme il y avait
rien qui avait été dit avant
lui. Te proposer un référendum
sur la langue française à
Montréal ça ne se fera pas. Si
ceci se faisait c'était un chaos
extraordinaire. Les gens qui
auraient pu voter pour cela
d'une part sont partis de
Montréal. Il y a huit villes qui
ont quitté Montréal dans
lesquels on retrouve l'essentiel
des anglophones de l'île de
Montréal et il ne voit plus à
Montréal. Il s'en va vers un mur
du point de vue de la
réalisation et de la faisabilité
ici Marc-Antoine Desjardins
avait encore un peu de bon sens
il devrait quitter cette
alliance pour garder sa
crédibilité.
- C'était ma question, est-ce
que Monsieur Desjardins ne se
rendra pas à la fin de la
campagne.
- C'est une question ou en tout
cas je ne lui ai pas parlé mais
je sais que dans le groupe il y
a beaucoup de gens qui ne sont
pas contents aujourd'hui parce
que c'était une entente. Il se
sent serrer la main et
habituellement si on sert sa
main, à mesure que l'entente est
scellée. La semaine passée,
photo dans la presse, tout était
là et aujourd'hui c'est comme si
rien ne s'était passé, on
continue et on fait son chemin.
Je trouve ça dommage, ça manque
un peu de maturité politique.
- Cette semaine, on va se
reparler, on va se reparler
cette semaine des propositions
de Mme Plante et de Monsieur